all right jason let's jump right into it
did you know the drama bomb you are
setting off by bringing emma on full
time to the o group
no
is that a is that a long enough answer
for you i i think it says a lot um it's
not the longest answer but it says a lot
i'm not really sure
what i've done wrong
it's like a sensitive subject
she was with christine's ex they were
engaged two months after we broke up so
emma is basically taking christine's
desk wow i hope you see it as a
professional decision
the timeline of this ex-boyfriend thing
is very confusing and convoluted there's
alternate timelines alternate facts how
aware of that were you
before it became a discussion on the
show you know i'm always surprised i
actually just watched the season myself
i guess i should say i'm not surprised
that there were issues with christine
and emma but i didn't think they'd be to
this extent i mean it was many years ago
that this
occurred but you know i guess it made
for good tv it makes for very good tv
your name i asked this because your name
gets brought into it because
christine kind of pulls people from the
o-group world into her timeline to try
and make her side of the story feel
accurate
when it seems at the end of the day
everyone believes emma over christine so
is what christine said the truth or is
she lying well i i know that that you'd
appreciate some type of definitive
answer from me but i'd rather stay out
of it i mean
um i
tend
to not
well no i should just play it safe but i
mean i know that i know the gentleman
you know he's a friend of mine um and
i'll just leave it at that fair enough
you you gotta keep the peace in the
office so you don't need anybody coming
after you um i guess at a certain point
what is the win-loss benefit of keeping
christine around because things at the
end of season four
feel pretty bleak for her and the other
women yeah i
will answer this by saying that
you need to watch season five
give me a tease of where we pick things
up on because season four ends christine
is at a crossroads she seems to be
making a decision one way or the other
of sticking at the o group or going off
i don't want to spoil season five do we
pick up right there though yeah because
we filmed season four and five straight
through
we just finished season five so
it should become it'll be coming out
pretty quick all right so it'll be a
speeding train that we yeah there was
really no gap in filming we went we
really just filmed i don't even know
sometimes what's on season four or
season five because we just film it
right there do you find the office to be
clicky or the politics of that surprise
you when you see how it plays out
watching the episodes back i don't see
the office as clicky you know i see it
as just about i mean we all
really all of us i mean krishel just had
an event a couple days ago
and we all came to support him i think
just about every single person from the
office i mean we
we had a a wrap party and
everyone came to that i mean there's one
you know
notable outlier but other than that i i
think everyone comes together all the
time and i would
there are a group of like best friends
um
and then there are a couple but i would
include i would consider everyone a
friend but then there are you know like
in every social dynamic there's like a
group of like you know best friends and
i think that's probably obvious from the
show but michelle and amanda and heather
and me and my brother and mary and uh
did i say emma i'm probably missing
people but you know they go out all the
time i mean
show or no show we're all best friends
and we all hang out all the time right
it is a reality show so we hope that the
reality that's presented on the show has
weight in the real world
um
mary seemed to end season four kind of
scorched earth with christine she had a
major meltdown at the dog party how
caught off guard were you by that moment
not really i mean i know mary has strong
feelings i think you know mary's very
sensitive and she internalizes
um conflict a lot and you know so her
process through conflict can sometimes
result in
her getting very upset because i don't
think you know like some people i think
uh deal with it in the moment all the
time and so it doesn't build up i think
with mary sometimes you know her
conflict resolution involves her
addressing things
um
not necessarily in the moment so i think
she expresses herself you know with some
feelings that have been building you
know that's on the show and in real life
with her yeah i think she even says that
herself on the the finale do you regret
not telling mary that christine was
coming to the dog party no
no i mean you know they're we're all
grown-ups all right you bring davina
back this season why did that feel like
the right move to make was it for the
show or was there a real business need
for her there's a real business need i
wouldn't bring somebody back for the
show i mean i've always liked defenite
and i think that she's a good agent and
i also believe in
you know second chances
um so i think she she's made a concerted
effort to be more positive and i've
honestly i credit her for that i think
she has been i think she's made a
visceral change so i i
and that's what she said she would do
and and i and i think that i think that
comes across in season five as well i
think that she uh
i think i'm proud of the way that she's
kind of addressed some of the criticisms
and uh and dealt with them
yeah you see kind of the wheels turning
for her
in the christine emma explosion of
getting caught in the drama and
realizing that's maybe not the place she
wants to live anymore um so i'm excited
to see what happens in season five what
happened with the 75 million dollar
house
uh nothing like you knew what happened
yeah i knew what happened i told
everyone what happened before we got the
listing is it still on the market just
sitting there i mean would he take a 75
million dollar
offer
yes
but we're not actively
you know trying to get it sold anymore
i'm not anyway right davina might be i
feel like she's probably gonna ask that
question every day
[Music]